does it make sense for me in the longer
term to build up
a wider set of experiences and skills
and opportunities and networks
by working across multiple businesses or
does it make more sense for me to work
in one job with one boss with
you know with one team
[Music]
suggested thank you for joining me on 20
minute leaders i'm so happy that you're
here
hi michael nice to see you thanks for
having me on your show
all the way from london correct that's
right yes
london tel aviv i just love how you know
in the middle of coven
and everything i still have the
opportunity to talk to people all around
the world
and but i'd like to start with your
journey even before we get to you've got
this and all the different things you're
doing now with
you know the future of work and what i'd
love to hear a little bit is about your
different experiences because you've
lived all across the u.s europe asia
right
tell me a little bit about your journey
yeah that's right so
prior to this i was working in financial
services so
i was working with the multinational
banks and i moved around quite a bit so
i started off in london i went to new
york uh that was during the financial
crisis
and then over to singapore in the
financial recovery
and then back to london to europe i went
to business school
and then and then did some work with
switzerland and hong kong
wow so what do you harness through all
these different experiences you've got
you've gotten to live and work and study
in all over the world
different cultures different types of
people different
work life balance and habits how do we
come out on the other end what are some
of your insights
what as we you know we are a much more
globalized world than we've ever been
what are some of the key takeaways that
you take with this diversification
yeah i think lots of things so i think
you know having the opportunity to see
those different
types of ways of working in in the kind
of corporate setting versus
the way of life and people's preferences
around that i think
in asia you know it's really popular
people where i was in singapore would
often get takeaway dinners and you know
there's really good food available from
the food courts and things like that
whereas here
in london my colleagues are cooking
themselves and and buying groceries on
the way home from work so that's that's
one difference
um i think secondly i think i took away
a appreciation for culture for
nuances for the way people operating and
then how that plays into team dynamics
as well
um so for example like a concept like
facetime or even just being able to
suggest ideas
up that up the hierarchy to the boss and
having those ideas acted on
in a kind of in a way that you feel that
your ideas are welcomed and
and can be um delivered on right
so as you transition from place to place
you have to adapt right and today
you know i'm looking at myself and all
my friends we have to move all the time
and i think this adaptation is
you know can be either quite challenging
or quite or quite helpful i actually
just had a beautiful episode
with somebody who's working on a social
platform to help work help
employees as they relocate to adapt so
how is the adaptation for you what did
you find most helpful
as you adapted both business-wise but
also personally
to all these different locations that
was a good question i think
for me you know working in those
different locations i think it was my
own mindset you know it's that
mindset that you know i'm going to
figure this out and you've been thrown
at the deep end
um you have to make new friends you have
to build new communities and
and and also then you know figure out
your new job um
so i think for me it was that
open-mindedness and then also you know
just the the response of the people
around you always you know when
i went to a new country somebody else
would introduce me to their friends and
that would really help me to then
um make more friends and and things like
that and then
you know professionally i think what
what's really helpful also is
is that being able to translate ideas
from one area into another
so being able to see patterns or
recognize ideas and concepts and then
translate them into other other business
lines
right so you know one of the things that
i that i have to say that
the name of your company you've got this
is perhaps the
the name that i love most out of any
company that i've seen so far because
it's just so fun to say you've got this
i and you know if you've got this i want
to have that role
what is you've got this and and why
why name your company like that yeah so
you've got this
it's a future of work sas marketplace
platform
what we're doing is connecting small
businesses with the expertise and the
skills that they need now
and on the other hand we're connecting
professionals people who've worked in
different
business areas or want to do something
different with their career to those
opportunities
so it's anything from six months to six
days to three months
wow and the reason though the way where
this came from is you've got this idea
is that often
a lot of people aren't actually in the
jobs that they love and they aren't
going through that process of trying
enough things to be able to know what it
is that they really want to do
and then on top of that you know with
with the environment that we're in a lot
of more people are looking for
flexibility for work-life balance
um so to be able to say you know i can
do this i can look after my family i can
look after
my career at the same time it's that
it's like idea of you've got this
unbelievable so take me back a little
bit let's imagine you know we're just in
the early stages and i
i know nothing about the industry and i
want you to tell me what is the pain
that you're solving here because
obviously the world is changing
at a drastically faster speed than we've
i perhaps anticipated especially
in this past 10 months or so and you
know the the way that startups
get talent get their things done is very
very different
you know obviously everything is remote
but besides that you know
geography boundaries are no longer
existent
in today's world and there's new
challenges to adapt to neutron
and new opportunities to to you know
harness
what is the world that we're moving
towards why do we need a company like
you've got this so when i was working
in fintech partnerships so i was meeting
lots of founders lots of
lots of new startup businesses who were
looking to grow in the financial
services sector
one thing i noticed was a lot of a lot
of teams were made up of founders they
were made up of co-founders of people
who
brought a range of skills but what they
were often missing sometimes was their
expertise it was it was expensive talent
people who knew the industry in and out
or a particular area that they were
trying to that they were trying to sell
their product into really well
and they weren't able to access that
talent locally
um so for example there are platforms
like upwork there is fiverr
but you can't really at the moment that
idea of somebody being
very much part of your team and and very
much a team member providing that
expertise that you and your team members
don't have currently
that's that's the basis of what we're
doing when i think about the future of
work i also think that there's a bigger
opportunity here to understand this idea
of a portfolio career
the side job the second job the third
job that in the future
as a professional somebody with skills
will want to kind of allocate their time
across different businesses where
there's demand and supply and
we're also we're seeing that already in
tech talent for example like you don't
often you know a developer is seen as
somebody who can be freelancing
and work on a number of different
projects in a professional way
i think that's going to become much more
broad much more mainstream
so what are the challenges that come
with that with with this you know
different
work ex work expectation from the
employee side how are the
employers going to to adhere to this
yeah i think i mean i think it's a
journey that we're on i don't think it's
changing today
um but i think what we're helping
businesses do is really understand the
composition of their teams
and helping them think about diversity
within their teams um so using the
platform as a way of understanding well
you know
as a as a business these are the skills
that we have and these ones we don't
have these are the ones that
potentially we could look to hire in in
the future um
you know these are the people that have
those skills and are really interested
in working with small businesses right
now
right so if i'm a small business and
let's say that i'm a software business
and i have you know
10 15 employees i'm solving a variety of
difficult challenges
what would be a use case where i would
come to you've got this
and and and ask for assistance what what
would be some of those use cases yeah so
we're enabling to search on skills and
sectors so the idea is that you're
looking for something
potentially with the sector expertise or
a skill particular skill or the
combination of both
um and you would i'm trying to think of
you know more specifically as to what
what it would be that the business is
solving but say for example it's a
it's a specific problem in fintech um
it's an
anti-money laundering solution um you
are trying to sell that to
ex-multinational bank um you really want
to understand what the what the
latest ideas and thinking around that
are um
you know what what things people have
tried what things that they're
interested in so it helps you to
get access to that exposure from say
somebody who's you know
worked in that area but it's now you
know left to
you know have children or to look after
elderly parents or something like that
you're tapping this pool of talent who
isn't necessarily available full-time
um but can be part of your team and
provide that necessary gap though
and then that arises some different
problems right if you're sharing your
time amongst different organizations
you know you have in just to get into
the culture and to get into the workflow
of a company is difficult but also
i imagine there might be some confusion
regarding intellectual property
or some you know anti-competitive
landscape so how do you how do you deal
with that
yeah i think a lot of these you know um
businesses you know
worry about things like that and i think
that's something that
you know we've very much built into our
platforms like you know other people
have with where you are you know relying
on the person to declare conflicts of
interest
and very much be aware that you know if
this if this is um
if this is not suitable then you don't
take on that business i think it's the
same with many industries that you have
to
you have to have that level of
boundaries between the businesses that
you're working on
and do you find anything difficult for
them for these people that are coming in
these
experts that are sharing their their
time
to the different organizations do they
have problems assimilating to the
culture or to keep up with what the
company is doing
or is it more or do you find that it's
actually easier than expected
i think there's a lot of people who are
interested in moving from the corporate
sector to small businesses
partly because they're looking for
meaningful work they're looking for
connection really that sense of
belonging and building the next future
of xyz
um i think that's where we're really
interested to
educate and help people make that
transition and i think you know that's
one of the things that you know we're
looking to partner with organizations
who understand that skills gap and
and can help us really work together to
move people from traditional roles to
the new
the new economy the tech economy and and
this type of work
how do how do you even get to think
about this problem well what in your
journey
led you to think about you know the
future of work
small businesses their needs their
problems and how you can address that
i think for me where where i was um
i think where i felt there was a real
need for this is when i thought about
the
the gig economy and i thought about the
gig economy following the last financial
crisis
and that led to the creation of
platforms like uber and delivery
and where i felt that there was still a
gap was in the higher skilled sector
and my my assumption and my hypothesis
is that that will as we
as we come out of this financial crisis
and or you know
as we come out of this recession um
we'll increasingly move towards
higher skilled work in the gig economy
interesting so
just to make sure that i understand
because actually i'm a huge fan of the
gig economy i've been using the gig
economy
since i believe 2014 or late 2013 for my
started back in high school simply
because we needed things done we didn't
have money to hire full-time employees
so we turned to platforms like
freelancer and upwork
but what i'm hearing from you is that
until now what the trend has been is
that you've had
you know the in the gig economy
primarily you've had
you know people that are not necessarily
in the highest skilled positions that
need you know years of academia and
expertise to get to the level where they
can contribute
from their sector and and now what
you're imagining in your thesis is that
as we transition more to the future of
work we're going to have more
higher skilled workers in the gig
economy potentially you know you're
going to have more phds in the gig
economy you're going to have more
you know nlp experts and computer vision
experts and that sort of stuff right
right interesting so what are the
benefits
really for the pers for the
person joining the gig economy to leave
let's say a company like
microsoft right or leave you know a high
paying job at boeing
to now go and be part of the gig economy
and take part in you know three
four small businesses at a time
so there's a few different parts to that
let me unpack it a little bit so the
first thing is
in the you know in the past having one
employer and having a full-time
employment contract meant
it was some level of risk aversion right
it was it was a job security
now in the future i think you know
putting all your eggs in one basket or
one business
may actually be more risky and i think
that's something which i think is really
interesting to try and understand a bit
more so
does it make sense for me in the longer
term to build up a
wider set of experiences and skills and
opportunities and networks
by working across multiple businesses or
does it make more sense for me to work
in one job with one boss with you know
with one team you know which one is
going to grow me and make me more
um i don't know flexible adaptable more
resilient to a downturn
and to this kind of future more um best
place for the future of work
and then the second thing is i think
it's going to be a graduate process i
don't think
many people you know with the very high
paying jobs particularly in something
like microsoft are going to be
interested in necessarily making that
jump or that leap on day one
and there's this idea that you know
maybe i can do it one day a week maybe i
can do it one day in a month and start
to build those relationships with
businesses where i'm
using my knowledge and skills to pass on
knowledge and ideas and information
separately and different business
verticals so i wouldn't expect it to be
a competitor business i'd expect it to
be a different industry or slightly
different
um problem that you know that the the
small business is facing
um but this idea that we can use that
knowledge and we can we can use that
under utilized capacity within
within our workforce i think that one of
the things that i i'm thinking towards
and in one in another episode we were
talking about you know the
efficiency of a worker and you know i
think that one thing that microsoft i
believe tried out this year was a three
day
work week or four day work week and they
actually found an increase in
productivity with
fewer hours of of you know hands-on work
and i think that that's and there's an
interesting analogy to be made here
and the speculation to be made here that
you know when we have a small amount of
time or when we have a problem we have
to solve
if you give me an hour to solve it or
give me two hours to solve it i'll
probably
get it get it done in both time frames
if it's the two hours i'll stretch it
out longer
and i see that for myself too when i
have when i allow myself you know seven
hours to do something i'll do it in
seven hours if i have one hour i'll do
it in one hour and it'll be done almost
at the same level
my imagination and what i think that
you're right here in speculating is that
you give somebody who's
highly skilled at something you you
allow them to spend their time working
on three different meaningful problems
they'll still manage to solve all three
whereas if they were only working on one
they would solve that one in the same
capacity
i think it's very interesting yeah i
think that's actually a very interesting
idea
and then and i look forward to seeing
where it goes
forward take me back a little bit to the
2008 recession because you mentioned
that gave room and rise to part of the
gig economy i'd love for you to expand
on that a little bit because
i was too young back then to know
economics and follow the news
so please tell me a little bit about
what happened over there
i think you know and i and i don't know
the details um
in a lot of detail but you know one of
the things that i i myself have
understood you know is
is from founders like will shu and and
um
and leah sullivan from taskrabbit is
that these you know these
these platforms were very much built
around that time and when they were able
to tap into the supply of
of people who wanted to work in a more
flexible way in order to make up lost
income and to to find work
and i think what we're seeing now if you
translate that forward
is you know yes there are a lot of
people who have been working in
professional services in banking
consulting finance
um who are now looking for work and and
have a bit of extra
extra time and one of the things with
furlough for example is that you're not
supposed to be working with your
business so
a lot of people are looking to start
building those relationships um you know
they're looking to protect themselves on
the downside risk of losing their jobs
as well
and if they have lost their job then
they're looking for new opportunities
either short term or long term
that makes a lot of sense so as an
entrepreneur you're looking at
you've got this how what's your plan of
growth what is sort of the strategy that
you're bringing to the table
as you're thinking to bring this to
market and potentially know
have every small business work with you
yeah so we're starting local in the
sense that we're very much focused on
on the uk market initially um we think
the us is our next best market after
that
um we're starting with small businesses
we you know we think the sme
is a market is the right place for us
right now um
and as we expand i think you know one of
the things we're going to be doing
next year is is using capital to to
invest in building our team
to to test new ideas to put things out
there and see how businesses respond and
very much in the agile kind of
development style that you
that you mentioned right and what's been
the reception
so far from those working with you and
and and getting to know about what
you're doing here
we've had a fantastic response i think a
lot of people are interested in the sas
idea
um where they can come to the
marketplace and and search and book as
many people as they want within a
certain band
um i think there's definitely more that
we can be doing to understand their
needs around
um certain types of skills and and
skills gaps that a lot of businesses
face so we're looking for patterns in in
the searches that people are doing
right and the decision to start off
locally in the uk is that primarily
because the team is located in the uk or
because there's an interesting
market theory of what's going on there
what was sort of the strategy of where
to start the piloting
yeah i think largely because we have a
better understanding of this market
um but i think you know the principles
on which you're applying are very much
global and with an increasingly remote
workforce but that's something that we
we want to really kind of play into a
lot within the future of work
right one of the things that i'm
assuming is that you know especially as
2021 will roll out you know remote work
and the geographical
barriers are going to dramatically
decrease and it doesn't really matter if
the small business is located in the us
uk israel or egypt you know the same
talent can be applied across the world
right now you know i know that i'm
working i have the opportunity to work
with teams literally all over the world
and it doesn't really matter where the
headquarters are or where
each person is as long as you're aligned
to some degree to
time zones but but i completely agree so
jetha i want to thank you for being so
generous with your time
it's been really fantastic and i loved
hearing about you've got this and your
different journeys and
your adaptations to the different
cultures that you've gotten to
experience
and i'd love to end with my favorite
question which is three words that you
would use to describe yourself
okay so i'm gonna give it a go i'd say
fun collaborative and an innovator fun
collaborative and an innovator
sujata thank you very very much this was
wonderful and
best of luck with you've got this and
stay safe and stay healthy
thank you so much great talking to you
michael thank you